RUBEN VAN DER STOCKT:
My name is Ruben.
I work as a customer
engineer within Google Cloud,
out of the Brussels office.
And the last three
and a half years, I
spent talking to a
lot of Enterprises
about Chrome and Android.
And in this session, I want
to talk to you about Chrome
and Android in the Enterprise.
What we've achieved,
but also what's
next with our
mobility solutions.
We think of Android and
Chrome as the beginning point
for a lot of our
Cloud solutions.
If you look at G Suite or any
application developed on Google
Cloud, they're best accessed
through Android and Chrome,
and we think that they
play well together.
Now, before we jump
into the presentation,
I just wanted to
give you the momentum
on both of these platforms.
And it's quite
American to pull up
a slide with a lot of numbers,
but they're quite impressive.
If you look at Android, 1.4
billion 30-day active users
are using an Android
smartphone today.
Consumers, Enterprise,
third world--
a lot of people are
using Android today.
There's about 1.5 million
Android devices activated
daily, so the rate is still
going up on the Android
adoption in the world.
So about 82% of the
smartphones in the world
out there are
Android-based devices.
If we look at the Enterprise
space, and the Android share
is considerably lower
than the 82% figure.
And we want to grow
this number, of course.
We want to grow the
market share of Android
within the Enterprise
space with a larger number.
And we know we have a few
challenges to overcome that.
Security, patching issues, a
lot of diversity of devices.
If you a Samsung device
and the Sony device,
they're completely different.
So we have huge challenges
to overcome in order
to grow that market share.
If we look at Chrome,
the first wave
of adoption of Chrome devices
was in the consumer space,
where even I gave
my mother a Chrome
device because every
time at Christmas,
she came to me to ask to
wipe her computer of all
of the viruses or a
software issue and so on.
I just gave her a Chrome device
with a Google mail solution
and it stopped.
Because basically all she
does is go into email,
do a few documents, calendar,
PC banking, and so on,
which is basically
all in the browser.
Second wave of adoption that we
saw is in the education space.
You might be aware of
the 52% market share
that we are getting in
the American public school
sector, where pupils are using
Chrome devices in order to get
teaching lessons and so on.
And what we've seen in the
last two to three years
is an adoption of Chrome
devices in the Enterprise space,
as well, because of the
security and the simplicity
of the solution, as well.
And a lot of applications
today are already
accessible through the
web browser, so why would
you still need a
[INAUDIBLE] client
with all of the
management capabilities?
About 800,000
Chromebooks are sold
to do the business annually.
And again, this is
definitely subject to growth.
But the reality is much starker.
If you look at the
total amount of workers,
3.25 billion workers
out there that
are still not connected
to any sort of device
to sort of functionality.
There's 750 million
PCs in business
that need to be replaced and
about 300 million managed
smartphone devices.
So there's definitely
an opportunity
for Chrome and Android
to grow into that space.
Of course, we can't
do this alone.
We do this with a
lot of our partners--
app developers,
OEMs, but also ISVs
that are writing,
specifically, applications
for both of these platforms.
So what do I want to cover
in this presentation?
First of all, let's give you
an overview of the ecosystem.
What is the ecosystem that
both Android and Chrome
can benefit from?
Let's look at Android and Chrome
in the Enterprise specifically.
Device management and security
are notably the two strongest
topics in this area.
And last but not
least, let's finish off
with some best practices
and new functionality
coming up in the O version.
The ecosystem.
I think the strongest
point on Android
is the application
developer community that
exists on Android.
Android Studio is one of
the most used development
platforms for applications
for mobile applications.
If you look at Play,
65 billion applications
are installed as of today
through the Google Play
environment.
And we basically offer a
good means for developers
to monetize on
their applications,
on their functionality.
But also for Enterprises to
develop specific applications
for their employees
and deliver them
through the Play ecosystem.
1 million applications plus
applications are available.
And of course,
these applications
are actively used today.
Today, this means that, through
the Google Play services,
you can deliver those
applications on smartphones,
tablets, and any other form
factor, like Google watches,
for example.
But also, we've opened
up the Chrome ecosystem
to be able to run Play Services
on top of a Chrome device.
So this basically means
that a Chrome device
capable of running Play
applications, Android
applications, is
able to run these 1
million available applications.
And this is very
useful if you have
offline capabilities-- if you
need offline capabilities.
For example, on my
work Chromebook,
I've enabled the Play store.
I downloaded the Netflix
Android applications
and I'm able to watch a Netflix
series offline on my Chromebook
device.
But think of mail in a more
professional environment.
But this gives you a bit
of a better understanding
of the capabilities
of the Chrome devices.
Applications are
very important to us,
and the huge success of Android
is also coming from the OEMs.
We've taken a bit of
a different approach
than our main
competitor in this area.
Where Android is
a very open system
and can be adapted
by a lot of the OEMs
to provide a specific
experience on their phones.
Again, a Samsung device is quite
different in a user experience
than a Sony or Pixel device.
This openness really
drives the ecosystem,
but it gave us a lot
of challenges, as well.
Because, well, manageability
and also security
becomes a very
difficult approach.
The most use case today is still
the smartphone and the tablet.
But if you have carriers
from DHL or PostNL,
they often use Android devices
to scan in your parcels,
as well.
We see Android devices popping
up in hospitals, or just
for nurses to be used for
their electronic patient files,
for example.
But we see the devices ecosystem
really growing, as well.
And we try to tackle
a lot of the issues
that we saw with the
diversity in this platform.
We try to tackle them.
On the Chrome side, as well,
a lot of new form factors
have been launched as of lately.
The majority of the use cases
that we saw for Chrome devices
were in the connected
worker space.
People using a Chrome device
to access functionality or use
the browser in order to go
into their applications, what
we saw, as well,
is that Chrome is
an ideal platform for
single application purposes,
like kiosks and so on.
The AOpen Chromebox
Mini, for example,
is a specifically
designed device
in order to run digital
signage or a single application
for a very long time.
They're industry grade and
they're designed to run 24/7.
And they're being used in
a lot of our Enterprises.
The ASUS Chromebooks, for
example, is the PC form factor,
and this is also being used
a lot in digital signage
environments.
By the way, the largest
deployment of Chrome devices
is in Europe-- is
Toyota Motor Europe.
So if you're entering
a showroom of Toyota
and you see a large screen
with the latest cars,
it's actually driven
by a Chrome device.
Of course, there's a huge
ecosystem behind it, as well.
And the one thing I
definitely want to mention
is the management piece.
We work very closely
together with the incumbents
in the mobile device
management space like AirWatch,
BlackBerry, MobileIron,
in order to make sure
that all of these devices that
enter into the Enterprise space
are managed in a proper way.
The feedback that we've
gotten from these EMMs
is that Android
is hard to manage.
One of the hardest
things to manage
is that there is no
consistent set of APIs
available for Android devices.
If you look at Lollipop, if you
look at KitKat, going further
along the stream, there
was always a different way
of managing these devices.
And often, they need a
device owner rights in order
to manage that device properly.
Device owner rights
is a Windows term.
It's just administrator rights.
You have access to
everything on that device.
We believe that
that's not secure.
So in collaboration with
these EMM providers,
we've created a
specific set of APIs
on which you can
manage the device
in the various constellations.
Whether that's a corporate-owned
single use case, device owner,
or personal use.
ISVs play a very
important role, as well.
We see ISVs developing Android
Enterprise-specific features,
as well.
For example, sales force.
If you deploy sales
force in a work profile,
it can act differently than
a sales force application
enrolled in a personal space.
Very important aspect.
So I've been talking
about Android Enterprise.
Let's look a bit at what
we're trying to achieve here.
I think that the strongest
point about Android
is that we're coming in
from a consumer angle.
A lot of people are using
Android at home already
and want to take that experience
into the Enterprise space.
And this conflicts quite
a lot with the Enterprise
organizations, or
organizations that
want to standardize or
want a very secure solution
in that place.
If in a Bring Your
Own Device scenario,
most of the organizations
demand to have
full control over that device.
Whether you want that or not,
it's quite often the case.
What we are trying to do
with Android Enterprise
is basically build in
those capabilities in order
to allow organizations
to use Androids in a very
secure and managed way.
We started off with Lollipop.
And for those who are
around for a longer time,
we called the name
Android for Work,
basically bringing
Android for Work.
But we decided to leave
the Android for Work part
and just keep it Android.
Because it's basically
a standard set.
If you buy a Pixel
phone today, Android
for Work or the Android
Enterprise capabilities
are built in.
We started off with Lollipop.
We gave the APIs, or
we described the APIs
and recommended to be
used by the OEMs, which
gave a bit of a
particular situation.
Because some phones
support it and some phones
didn't support it, so there
was a bit of ambiguity.
So we didn't Marshmallow.
We basically said, OK, if you
want to run Play Services,
if you want to run Google
applications on top
of your smartphone,
you need to fulfill
all of the requirements
that are needed
to run Android Enterprise.
As a reminder,
Android Enterprise
are a standard set of APIs
that can be used by an EMM
to manage those
devices by a EMM.
There were two use cases.
One was BYOD, so basically
bringing your own phone,
adding a second profile, which
is managed by the organization.
If you leave the organization,
you can wipe off that profile
and still use the personal site.
And we also offer the
corporate-owned version,
as well.
So basically, having
a phone that's
been provided by the Enterprise
completely locked down
for that aspect.
In Nougat-- by the way,
we also added requirements
for encryption
for these devices.
So any Marshmallow
device out there
has a default encryption
built into those devices.
Certainly from a security point
of view, that's very strong.
Nougat, further usability
enhancement of management.
There were a few hiccups with
regards to Identity Provision.
That's all being solved and
it's very easy to be used.
And of course, we are still
developing more and more
into the O release coming up.
What does it look like if you're
looking at a personal device
from a work profile way?
If you are using G Suite
today, this is already
available for you to test out.
So if you have a Marshmallow
and onwards Android
device, what you are able to do
is activate the work profile.
And what it basically does is
you have your personal phone,
which is initiated with
your personal Gmail address,
and you do whatever
you want on that phone
because that's a personal space.
But what you're adding
is a second profile
on that device which
is completely managed
by the organization.
Organization can put
applications into that,
can also require, for example,
an additional pin code.
So if you want to enter
this work profile,
you need to enter
specific Pin code in order
to access your
work applications.
But what's really
neat about this
is the complete separation
between personal and work data.
From a user perspective,
my favorite feature
of running this work profile is
that I can switch off the work
profile when I'm at home.
So I just drag down the action
list, tap on the work profile,
and all of my work
applications are grayed out.
No notifications.
And if I get an incoming call,
because my work profile is
closed, it cannot
access my work contacts,
so I know that that might be
somebody from work calling.
I'm quite harsh on
my work-life balance.
Also, it's
independently lockable.
That's what I
explained, as well.
And a company can
remotely wipe all
of the contents of that
phone without touching
the personal side
on that matter.
If we look at
corporate-owned devices--
these are devices
owned by corporate
and then given to an end user--
we do have some very good
management capabilities
in there.
Of course, the reset
wipe and managed
reset protection is in there.
If anybody has ever managed an
Android device and accidentally
set up the factory
reset protection.
So I have a customer who had 100
phones activated with one Gmail
address.
Some of them left and then
they wiped the whole device.
If you want to
reuse that device,
you need to have the password
of that personal account.
So some of these
devices became lockable.
With corporate-owned,
you absolutely lose that.
You can also manage
the OTA update policy.
So if you want to
have your devices
receive the latest and
greatest on those devices--
and we absolutely recommend it.
So Google has done
a great effort
to separate out the
functionality updates
from the security updates.
So functionality
updates need to go
through a whole series
of testing by a carrier,
by an OEM, before they can
be released to a phone.
With security updates, we
have taken functionality
away so that carriers
and OEMs can easily
apply the security settings.
And a lot of these
large corporations,
like Samsung and BlackBerry, are
doing this for their flagship
accounts.
And we absolutely
recommend, if you're
buying a large bulk of devices,
to have this as a requirement
when you buy these devices.
Another thing that
plays into mind
when you're talking about
Enterprise capabilities--
so you have the device
and default set of APIs.
Next, what we're
offering in that space
is the managed play environment.
So as an organization,
you have a specific set
of the Play Store available
in which you can whitelist
the applications you want
to be using into that work
environment.
From a security point of
view, this is quite unique.
Because you, as an
organization, decide
what applications are running.
So you can make the assessment
whether an application
is a potential harmful
application, yes or no.
There's no other way
to install applications
into a work profile.
So that takes away
all of the risks
of having a potential harmful
application into your work
profile.
The sources can be
public, so you don't have
to do any application wrapping.
You just select the
application that can
run on an Enterprise profile.
Or you can host your
APK at Google, or even
at your own premises.
But you use the Google Play
Store as the application
installation, or application
delivery mechanism.
Of course, there's a very
close connection with the EMMs
so that you have a single
source where you all
of this, of course.
We deploy them.
So the EMM, basically, you
whitelist the applications
from an EMM point of view.
You push the
applications, silently
install these
applications onto a phone,
or you can have the Play Store
as a self-service portal.
So if end user wants to install
box or sales force or whatever,
he's able to do that because
you, as an organization,
are allowing this.
Control the auto updates.
And what's also very new
is applying application
configurations to it, as well.
So if you deploy a mail
client, you already
give it a configuration
with that mail client
so a user doesn't
have to fiddle around
with any of the settings.
What is less known
is that Google Play
plays a very important aspect
in the security element.
So if you're looking
at the Play Services,
we basically do a lot on the
antivirus side of things.
So if you look at the
Play applications host
that within the Play store,
we do static controls.
So we basically run--
we check the code
base of an APK,
but we also do dynamic testing
of all of these applications.
So basically, running
these applications
in a real-time
environment to check
what an application is doing
and whether that application is
exactly doing what
it says it does.
In that case, we can
already take away
a lot of these applications
that are basically
camouflaging all of the
elements that they're doing.
We also provide
device scans per day.
So if you're an Android
user, we basically
scan the device for you.
There's a lot of anti-virus
applications on Android
existing today.
This is absolutely not necessary
because we take care of this,
as well.
What is less known
is that we also
check the image of an
Android device, as well.
So if you look at the
certification process,
I said, well, if you want to
run the Play Services and Google
applications on top
of an Android device,
you need to fulfill
a certification
or a set of requirements.
Because we do that,
we scan the image,
we know exactly
what the code base
looks like of a
Samsung S6 out of 2014
with carrier [INAUDIBLE].
So we have a lot
of images available
of specific configurations.
If somebody tries to root
or has rooted his device,
it has changed the code base
of the ROM of the system.
So what we basically do
is we have an attestation
API that can be called by, for
example, a banking application.
So if the ING application
calls on this attestation
application, it can
check whether the image
that application is running on
is still to verify one or not.
And based on that
information, you
can take away the installation.
So there's definitely a lot
happening on the background.
Chrome OS.
Again, this was always--
so I focused on
the two platforms,
so Chrome and Android
in the Enterprise space.
There's two different
use cases for this.
I had a lot of questions around
security on the Android side.
With Chrome OS, I won the heart
of a lot of security officers,
in such a sense that
some of the largest
banks in the UK, the
security officers
were running around with a
Chrome device accessing Citrix.
Because on the end point,
there was absolutely no data.
They just used the
Chrome device in order
to access the information
on their own back end.
And it was a very,
very strong point.
We've always covered Chrome
was on all four topics.
Speed, simplicity,
security, and shareability.
Because of its very,
very warm here,
I will not go into
a lot of details.
We're all longing to
a good, cold drink.
I am definitely one of them.
But I just wanted to go
over them very quickly.
Speed.
If you've ever used
a Chrome device,
it's just opening a lid, waiting
six seconds, start typing,
and you have all of
the functionality
that you ever need.
I was a Mac user and before
that, I was a Windows user.
There were times that
I opened up my laptop,
pushed the power button,
went for a coffee
and maybe I was in time
to type in my password.
What we've done is we stripped
down a version of Linux
and made it so that you can
only run a browser on top of it.
And with every
release of Chrome OS,
one thing that is
very important is
that if we add
additional functionality,
the Chrome OS needs to be
fostered in a previous version.
If you take an old
Chromebook on version 24,
update it to version
60 today, the device
will guarantee it
will run faster,
will run smoother, than before.
Simple.
I already gave the
example of my mother.
The only thing she
needs to do is log in
with her Gmail address
and she has access to it.
And also, I've
been playing around
with a lot of technology,
but the simplicity
is still the one that
really grabs my mind.
Secure, as well.
Because it's a
browser, you can't
install any software, any
DLLs, or any applications
on top of it.
Well, basically,
this takes away all
of the potential
harmful applications.
Basically, we are even
challenging the hacker
community on Chrome OS
to hack into Chrome OS.
If you find a vulnerability
and we verified it,
we will pay you $100,000 in
order to prove this leak.
And trust me, there is a lot
of people trying to do that.
But today, the track
record is completely clean.
Shareability.
There is a lot of use cases.
So if you look at the
information worker who
has his own laptop or
his own Chromebook,
shareability is not a big issue.
But if, for example, my
Chromebook breaks down
and I log in to my colleague's
one, that's perfectly fine.
Because what you
do, every time you
log into your Chrome device,
it creates a root directory,
or it creates a directory for
the user, which is encrypted
by that username and password.
There's no notion of an admin.
There's no notion
of somebody who
can access that information
other than the user that
has that username and password.
What's very neat about
this shareability aspect is
that, with a managed
environment-- so for example,
we have a huge
project with a UK bank
where employees who are logging
in with their bank account,
it's a completely
lockdown environment.
No video camera, no
microphones, no SD cards.
Only Citrix can
run as a plug-in.
That's the only thing it can do.
It can access Citrix.
That's it.
But if he logs out, logs
in with his Gmail address,
he has a full completely working
Chrome device in front of him.
So highly regulated
industries, and also
the freedom of using your
own username on that device.
Of course, this is completely
manageable, as well.
Let's talk about applications
on Chrome devices.
And one of the strongest points,
or about 80% of a project
I've been working
on, we're always
related with
virtualization software.
And we believe that
virtualization software
is a stepping stone into a
fully Cloud-based workplace.
And our end goal is, of course,
that all of the applications
you access is through a browser.
VMware in Citrix
and the other cloud,
they have provided
some solutions in order
to provide functionality
into a browser.
Citrix and VMware are
the most advanced ones.
And basically, what
you're able to do
is swap out your thin clients
and use a Chrome device
instead.
And we freed up a
lot of employees
from being tied behind a desk
with a thin client and one
screen and a keyboard and
a mouse to a Chrome device
that they can carry with
them in meeting rooms
or can go into another office
with their own personal device.
This works quite well.
Of course, the one thing
that I didn't mention
is the availability of
the play applications
or the Android applications
on top of Chrome.
What we've done here is a bit
of a specific implementation
of containers.
So there's basically
an Android device
running on Chrome
bare metal, and we've
intertwined the interface
so that it's really
just one interface.
So it doesn't matter
whether you're
accessing a
Windows-based application
through virtualization, a native
web application, or an Android
application.
It all looks the
same to the end user.
What's particularly
interesting about Chrome
is the connection with
the device management.
And the device
management basically
allows you to control any
aspect of a Chrome device.
From the hardware sites,
so from devices side,
from a remote point of view,
you can change the behavior
of the device within seconds.
So if you want to
say, OK, this person
has moved into a
different role where
he has less access
to applications,
you can basically
limit that immediately
by changing some
of these aspects.
What's very nice,
as well, is that you
can buy from any source, so any
commercially available Chrome
device.
If you buy them, they act
as just a consumer device.
Once you've enrolled them
into the management console,
you gain complete access to it.
So configuring a device,
we've seen it in many cases,
takes quite less time.
Before that, they
took out the laptop,
they installed a
specific image, they
started to install software,
and then, after half a day,
they can give the
laptop to an employee.
Now in this case, they just
grab the Chrome device,
tap Control-Alt-E, log in
with an admin or a user that
is known within the device,
and you can ship that out
to an end user.
Because in that case, this
is completely managed.
Remote lock and ultimate
security, of course.
So if you leave a Chrome
device on the train,
well, the data on that
device is already minimal
because you use the browser
and downloading software,
downloading data is
not really happening.
But using the encryption
on the user level,
a data thief cannot get access
to that from an encryption
point of view.
And even if he tries to
take out the hard disk
and try to put in another hard
disk into that Chrome device,
the device won't boot
because the hard disk
is known as a known
configuration within Chrome OS.
It's very complex, in that case.
Native security hardware.
In every Chrome
device, there's a TPM--
trusted platform model chip.
We provide the operating
system and updates.
Again, a bit different than
the Android site, and we're
trying to copy a lot
of the Chrome site
into the Android site.
So we, as Google,
every six weeks,
there's a new
version of Chrome OS
no matter what kind of
device you're using,
whether that's a Chromebook
Flip, a Chromebit,
or a Chromebase,
it's one codebase.
It's just one operating system.
We have a profound use
of sandboxing, as well.
Basically meaning that every
service runs in its own sandbox
and can only give
access or has access
to certain data
particles or programs
on the device by policy.
So let's look at a few
of the best practices.
If we're looking at
mobile device management--
or mobile devices--
we see for access.
And let's start in
the left lower corner
with an unmanaged device.
An unmanaged device is
just a feature phone
or a phone that's being
used and is not connected
to the Enterprise in any way.
One abstract layer
on top of that
is basically the personal
usage of a device,
adding a work
profile on top of it.
Now, the best
practice in this is
that the minimal requirement
that we recommend
is Marshmallow.
Marshmallow devices have
Android Enterprise capabilities
built in, have that Android
work profile, by default,
in their APIs.
So this basically
allows organizations
to have the EMM manage that
work profile on top of it.
The second layer on top of
that is a managed device.
This is a corporate-owned,
personal enabled device.
Basically, the organization
or the employer
is in charge of this device.
Again, Marshmallow is the
least operating system
that we recommend
in that case because
of the standard
encryption, and also
the addition of the
default APIs in that case.
Last but not least,
the dedicated devices
within the Android
Enterprise capabilities,
we've also added kiosk
usage into the Android
images and the APIs.
Basically, giving a
consistent management
of single applications
on those devices.
So think of a tablet running
just one single application
at kiosks in shops, for
example, or for digital signage.
This is added, as well.
Do not use unknown sources
and force verify apps.
There's still a major EMM
that requires the user
to turn off this feature.
If you ever download it from
Chrome browser or any browser
APK, if you try to
install that on Android,
it will give you a
Warning saying, hey,
you cannot install this
because this is an unverified
application.
We always recommend
installing applications
from the Play Store because of
the reasons I just explained.
We do a lot of
research, we do a lot
of testing on the applications.
So we think the
Play and, certainly,
the whitelisted applications in
Play, are the most secure way
to use applications.
So please do not set the policy
that unknown sources cannot be
switched off.
It's a default policy.
Required device encryption.
Of course, I cannot
stress on this.
If you leave your
phone on the train,
you want to make sure that the
device is encrypted by default.
And we've done a
lot of work in order
to make sure that personal and
business data is separately
encrypted, as well.
Enforced minimal
security update policies.
Again, if you're buying
a lot of devices,
please make sure that the
OEM you are buying from
is guaranteeing that you get
monthly security updates.
We try to be the best
pupil in the class,
so if you buy a Pixel
phone, we guarantee
that, at least two years, you
will receive monthly security
updates for these
devices, as well.
And a lot of the OEMs are
following this, as well,
because they see
that security is very
important in a lot of cases.
Separate management of
work and personal data.
Again, from a user perspective,
personally, I quite
like the separation of
work and personal data.
Because I know that what
I do in my personal set
is completely separated from
my data from my work profile.
Again, if you're working with
a lot of photos, some photos
you don't want to end up in
the work profile, of course.
I use the latest
available Management APIs.
So what's next?
I've talked about
a few use cases.
So Bring Your Own Device.
You have your personal
profile with a work profile
on top of it, which is
managed by the organization.
Well, some of our
customers said, we
want it the other way around.
We have a corporate-owned
device and we
want to enable a
personal profile to it so
that the user can still
do it, but we remain 100%
in control over
the complete phone.
So that's something that
we are launching in O.
So this will
basically allow users
to add their own
personal profile for it
in a corporate-owned
device, still
maintaining the whole data
separation on top of it.
We are probably not using
the work profile icon.
It will be something
different because then it's
the other way around.
It might be
confusing if you want
to access personal information
through an application that
has a work batch on it.
So that will probably go away.
What we're doing in O,
as well, is separately
encrypt the data from the work
profile and the personal space.
Again, in case you want to
wipe a device, in that case,
you just have to throw away the
encryption key of the work site
so that any application or
any data cannot be accessed
afterwards.
We are adding new privacy
notices on corporate devices.
A huge feedback because if
you're working on a work
managed or a work
profile device,
some of the capabilities
on the personal side
can be switched off, as well.
We've added the capabilities to
add some help notes, as well.
So basically saying,
OK, your corporation
has switched of this
setting because of this.
Or you can contact
your organization.
This is quite handy, as well.
So basically, if you lose a
phone, in Android, by default,
you're able to say, OK, this
phone is for me with a phone
number so that people can
return the phone if they
haven't stolen it.
This can be set by
corporate policy, as well.
So basically saying, OK,
this is the service desk.
If you find this phone, please
return it to this organization.
Device provisioning.
The second topic.
So security in Android.
The second topic was
device provisioning.
The other phone
manufacturer out there
that's competing with
Android has a very, very neat
mechanism.
You just provide the serial
number and once a user
opens up or boots that phone,
it's automatically enrolled
within the EMM, for example.
With Android, that's
quite different
because we don't own the
hardware of that device.
We don't know what the
device is and we don't
know who it's attached to.
We are trying to work
on a way in order
to mimic that situation.
And you will see that
with Pixel phones already.
If you buy a Pixel
phone in bulk,
you get a set of
IMEI numbers, which
you can upload into a portal.
And once that device
boots up, the device
will be automatically enrolled
within the mobile device
management console.
We're working on
QR codes, as well.
So if you can scan a code, then
it will automatically enroll.
NFC tokens, as well,
is something that's
available in the near future.
Work profile improvements.
Verify Apps strict mode.
Stricter enforcement
of verify applications,
and verify applications
is our antivirus solution.
So we're extending
that functionality
in a lot more phones.
So basically, able
to scan those phones
at any time at any place.
And new APIs will be
available, as well.
I basically mentioned
this, as well.
On the Chrome site,
this is a device
that will come out in
Europe quickly, as well.
This is the new
flagship Chrome device.
This is the Samsung
Chrome device.
They're re-entering
the Chrome market.
And this is a premium,
two-in-one Chromebook offering.
We often get the question,
like, you have Android
and you have Chrome
as a platform.
Why maintain both?
Well, we think that Android
is great for mobility
for internet of things
for smaller devices
to consume information.
We think Chrome is more of
a productivity platform.
And what you will
be seeing, there
was a huge strict separation
between tablets and Chrome
devices.
There was never a Chrome tablet.
We are now investigating, or
re-investigating, that aspect.
So in the first phase, you will
see this sort of convertible.
So you can use this as a tablet,
and we've done a lot of work
to have the stylus working
very well on a Chrome device.
I see, in the near
future, that you
could work on some detachables,
or even on a Chrome device.
And this is very
useful in kiosk usage
because you have a very
strong, secure device.
It's a very shareable device.
But still have that mobility
grasp, as well, with Chrome OS.
It's quite a nice device.
A big announcement, as
well, is with VMware.
So VMware offers
virtualization software,
so you have virtual applications
that can run on a Chrome
device, as well.
The Chrome device
management piece
was something you could
only buy from Google.
So you buy a license and you
can manage your Chrome device.
What we've done is we've opened
up that device management
capabilities by
opening up the APIs.
And what VMware has done is they
have incorporated these APIs
into their device
management capabilities.
So if you already have a VMware
workspace, one environment,
you now can manage these
devices through that workspace,
as well.
And we see a lot of
new things popping up,
as well, new ways of
managing devices, as well.
Active Directory, for
example, is a lot used
within the Enterprise space.
A lot of people are not yet
in the Google ecosystem,
so we're looking
for simpler ways
of managing Chrome devices
out of the Active Directory,
for example, opening up
a lot of new use cases.
So to conclude the
session, I hope
it was useful, first of all.
Thanks for staying in the room,
even when it's now 36 degrees.
If you want to test drive the
Android management experience,
or if you want to
verify what your EMM is
telling is the truth, there's
the Android management
experience.
So if you look at
this link, and I
think these slides
will be shared,
it basically allows you to have
the managed Android experience
without setting up all of
the management capabilities.
So it's a very useful way to
test out all of these APIs.
And if you're really interested
in the connected workspaces,
in where the cloud
meets the devices,
I invite you to look at this
connected workspaces page,
as well, which
shows, a bit more,
the capabilities
of what's possible,
what's next with these devices.
So thank you very much
and hope you enjoyed it.
And let's go for a drink.
[APPLAUSE]